-Musician Dave Matthews
has announced
he's coming out with
a line of rosé,
news that has all
your aunts marching.
[ Laughter ]
This brings us to a segmen
called
"One of My Writers
Explains a Joke."
♪♪♪♪
[ Cheers and applause ]
-Hey, everybody.
This is Mike Scollins.
How are you, Mike?
-Well, how are you?
-Good. I'm gonna read this
one more time.
Musician Dave Matthews
has announced
he's coming out with a lin
of rosé,
news that has all your aunts
marching.
You want to talk us throug
your thought process there
[ Laughter ]
-Sure, yeah.
To get this joke,
first you got to know that
"Ants Marching"
is a Dave Matthews Band song
off of
"Under the Table and Dreaming.
Really great album
top to bottom.
[ Laughter ]
Fully holds up.
Okay. So "Ants Marching"
is about these ants
that are, like,
having a really great day
so they, like, throw a parad
or whatever,
and then -- so now we know
what the song's about.
And now there's this added
element of Dave Matthews
has a new rosé, and I was like
"Do you know who would hav
a parade about that is aunts -
not the bug, but aunt,
like your mom or dad's sister.
[ Laughter ]
-And do you think --
[ Cheers and applause ]
Do you think based on
the audience's reaction
when I first told the joke
that they're as familiar
with Dave Matthews as you are?
[ Laughter ]
-I don't think anybody is.
-Yeah.
[ Laughter ]
And, Mike, is it true that
you were nominated
for a writing Emmy today?
-I hope they don't take it away.
[ Laughter ]
[ Cheers and applause ]
-Mike Scollins, everybody!
-This has been "One of
My Writers Explains a Joke."